Like, who cares what Casey Tron's saying
here? She's being forced to say it.
Like, how do you even watch this and get
anything out of it? [clears throat]
So, yeah. So, yeah, she had to read this
or she was going to lose a house.
Something that should concern a
commentary YouTuber, but I guess Nick
has totally forgotten all those
principles that he used to [music]
espouse so [__] heavily in like every
video on his channel.
>> I don't feel this is 3 hours 16. The
other one's 230 minutes. So, I'll let
you do the conversions in your head. So,
if everyone remembers, there's been a
lawsuit going on
started by Ethan Klene against three
content creators, Caseyron,
Frogan, and Denims.
also implicating moderators and users of
the H3 snark leftovers H3 subreddit
for I believe contributo copyright
infringement for linking their streams
and directing people to watch it
instead.
Um, obviously anyone with sense
saw through Ethan's thin
facade
that this was about forming some kind of
precedent for React content ethics on
Twitch and YouTube.
And most people have dropped that
pretense. I watched a little bit of Nick
Dioro's coverage and I saw he's totally
dropped that pretense. No one pretty no
one who's got like any kind of
reputation or anything is operating
under the pretense that Ethan's doing a
good thing here or is doing it for
selfless or principled reasons. uh
anyone with any sense has acknowledged
now it is entirely malicious and
essentially it's a uh dishonest
malicious use of the copyright
infringement law to hash out uh uh
personal beefs personal beefs and what
should be a defamation matter. If you
believe these people have lied about
you, damaged your business with their
lies,
then you should sue them for defamation.
You should not sue them for copyright
infringement. You certainly shouldn't
construct some bizarre gay like internet
super villain 4D chess thing where
you're like, "Oh, I'm going to do
exactly what Ryan Kavanaaugh did to me
to them. I'm going to I'm going to
register something with the Library of
Congress and then use it to compel
speech in a settlement." something that
any self-respecting commentary YouTuber
should be against, by the way, because
obviously this could happen to anyone.
They could anyone could do this to you.
Any rich person could do this to you as
long as they've got more money than you
and they know they can outlast you in
court. Uh they can create a video that
you're likely to react to if you're a
streamer, if you're a cont commentary
streamer. They can create a video that
you're likely to react to, register with
the Library of Congress, drown you in a
lawsuit, and then try and force you into
a settlement where your speech is is
compelled or totally silenced. Because
this is something I haven't heard
brought up. I haven't heard Ethan say,
"Oh, by the way, Casey Tron's changing
of her own valition because there's no
non-disparagement agreement. There's no
non-disclosure agreement about the
settlement." So Casey Tron can say
whatever she likes. She's just going to
choose not to. She's I haven't heard
that said whatsoever. I've not heard
that said at any point. Uh so I'm
assuming Casey Tron is essentially
legally muzzled. That's that's the sense
I'm getting right now. is that Ethan has
used this. He has dishonestly,
maliciously used a statute that does not
apply to the issue he actually wants to
hash out in order to maliciously silence
someone to quell their speech and compel
their speech.
So, anyone, regardless of whether you
dislike the person and think they're a
fat, you know, whatever the [__] think
they're a disgusting
lazy [__] who steals content, whatever
you think.
If you're someone that cares about free
speech or having a healthy online
ecosystem for criticism of larger
creators, this should be something that
concerns you. Be something that concerns
you deeply because it's not a good
precedent to set that people start doing
this. And one of the jobs, something
that Nick Durio knows, by the way,
because he said, "Oh, seeing stuff like
this happen means we're not doing a good
enough job about other situations."
Something that all these people know is
that when a situation like this happens,
you should be attempting to make the
cost of success greater than any loss
would have been. The fact that Ethan is
able to do this should mean that as you
know interested parties, you ensure he
pays a greater price for winning than he
ever would for losing.
That should be your mindset as someone
that cares about this sort of thing.
Now, many people don't care about this
sort of thing. Many people are just
wretched, despicable [__] low lives
who get on the internet and want bigger
content creators to fight their battles
for them and and lash out against their
enemies for them because they don't feel
confident making arguments on their own.
So, they just take them downstream from
someone bigger that it can essentially
deflect and hide behind and then if heat
gets too high, they just go, "Oh, I
disavow. I disavow and step away."
That's what some wretched [__] low
lives who spend years grandstand you
about this sort of thing. That's the
sort of attitude they approach approach
us with. Okay.
So, we're going to take a look at the
Casey Trron apology, the ISIS beheading
video. Um, and then we're going to well,
we're going to look at that. But first,
we're going to take a look at uh Ethan's
apology to Ryan Kavanaaugh because it's
just very obvious where he got all the
ideas for this from. So, let's let's
take a look. one front so that I can
open several more. And it's time to turn
a leaf and to close the chapter with my
dear friend
Ryan Kavanaaugh.
[snorts] Um, we've come to an agreement
and we are parting ways.
We are settling the matter amicably
and I have a statement that I've
arranged.
>> [cough and clears throat]
>> excuse me,
with my good friend
that we've that that I would like to
state for you now in all sincerity and
to close the chapter and move right
along.
>> Wow.
>> So, here is my apology
>> to Ryan Kavanaaugh. I read to you now
to Ryan Kavanaaugh. I want to offer my
sincere and unreserved apology. At the
time, I was led to believe you were
behind a particular copyright lawsuit.
Acting [snorts] on that belief, I went
on and attacked you publicly and
persistently. In doing so, I failed to
consider the personal impact of my
actions. And I lost sight of the basic
respect every person deserves regardless
of any dispute. That's
that hit its home. You know, I also
understand that as a result, your
Wikipedia page has been significantly
altered to reflect you in a negative
light. And I apologize for any
involvement I had in that. I apologize
for ever making statements that led
anyone to believe you were involved in
unethical or bad business dealings.
>> And I now know that any of those things
I may have
>> any time you're on camp of Mr. Liam
Donovan on the side so people can
realize the path not taken.
>> Thank you for the $5 moment. Thank you.
I deeply regret ever elevating or
emphasizing that false narrative and it
was wrong of me and I apologize
because of the attention I placed on
you. I know that you and your family
became the target of harassment and hate
and truly none of them deserved any of
that. Uh the hurt that you know was
caused by my actions is something I take
full responsibility for and I am truly
sorry for that.
I also understand that the negative
social media and what
>> like this is just what he did to
Caseron. It's the same thing. It's the
same thing except Ethan was sued for
things he actually did that Ryan
Kavanaaugh was actually upset about for
the right things. lost it fair and
square with no like extra scheming or
like deception that had to be done with
registering videos before they went out
to try and put them in a trap or in
Denim's case realizing that she actually
did quite a good reaction to your video
and then registering the stream you did
counting down to the release of the
video after the fact so that you could
catch her in a less transformative
moment of the stream so you could so you
could catch her on that in Denim's case
but focus on Casey Trump today folks on
case Robert today
>> Wikipedia edits have placed on you and
your business and again I I apologize
for my involvement I had in and that and
I hope that any such issues can be
retracted right and that you do not have
to
>> we are not doing hair comments every
[__] day so just give it a rest
>> further issues as a result of those
>> holy [__]
>> [laughter]
>> Truly,
we have since come to peace and I'm
thankful for the opportunity to move
forward.
>> You know, with this apology and with
full respect, I ask that anybody
>> who may have been acting on my behalf
directly or indirectly,
stop immediately.
Ryan and his family and his associates,
>> even if you're saying something
positive,
>> should be left alone now for good.
>> It's incessant.
>> I truly mean that. I I mean I mean
everything I'm saying, but I really want
to make sure that like we we turn the
page on this, you know, and and we just
I'm apologizing to Ryan and we're moving
forward like doves. We're dogs now. Both
of us wish to move on with our lives and
I wish Ryan and his family bear
>> in mind Ethan was using retracted claims
that this guy ran a Ponzi scheme. Lally
the article that accused him of it
retracted it before Ethan started
running the allegation.
He he runs the allegation regardless and
he gets sued for defamation rightfully.
And he was comparing this guy what's all
going on. He's comparing this guy to
Harvey Weinstein saying he looks like
Harvey Weinstein. He might have
skeletons in his closet and all this
[__] too. That's the sort of [__] Ethan
was saying about this guy. What was
Casey Tron saying that was anywhere near
that? the the most like insane thing
that Casey Tron said is girl killed his
mom. Sorry, you're gonna have to I'm
gonna really struggle to give a [__]
about that. I'm going to be real. Like
seriously, what who gives a [__] man?
Who gives a [__]
Peace, privacy, and all the best in the
future. And I do. And um
so there it is there. that and that
closes the chapter of uh
>> yeah he made harassment websites on Ryan
>> Kavanagh my good friend Ryan Kavanagh
who you know we it's it's been a journey
I'm improving now which is probably a
bad idea but
>> you think
>> I want to say that um I I we're friends
we're dogs it's all good and I am deeply
apologetic for everything that that
we've been through so there it is Ryan
Kavanagh everybody thank you and that's
it
[snorts]
>> you guys want to talk about the Zalinsky
suit scandal
>> wow
Wow. Great, great stuff, Ethan. Okay, I
was going to watch just the Casey John
thing, but I think we'll watch Ethan's
reaction to it. I don't think we'll do
both. I think we'll just do one of them.
Um, but before I get on to that part, we
actually probably should watch something
else. Well, we'll look at something
else. One second
cuz I think Peace Go's post actually
came up before
the apology came out.
Let's read some of Pisco's posts here.
So, Pisco says, "Alleged Ethan Klein
settlement with Casey Trron further
supports everything I've been saying.
I'm aware there is other litigation
ongoing, but this case was never about
protecting the React community from a
potential lawsuit from Disney or Sony."
Ethan's words, not mine. Nor was it
about helping enforce a standard on the
React community. Ethan's central
framing, not mine. This case was never
going to establish a precedent, legal or
cultural, on the React community, other
than what is already wellknown in
American life. Those with resources are
able to vindicate their property rights
using the courts.
And there's nothing inherently wrong
with someone protecting their IP,
especially not in a strong case, which
I've always maintained this was. What I
take issue with has been specifically
focused on the pretense that the lawsuit
is about something greater than that,
than protecting property and punishing
and humiliating the defendants for their
transgressions, perceived or real,
against Ethan. In his video, Ethan
constructs a fake narrative about
protecting the React community,
presumably because one, he is aware that
trigger-happy litigation bros are not
usually wellreceived on YouTube, but
when it's the big guy going after the
little when it's the big guy going after
the little guy, and two, Ethan didn't
like to give the answer because I don't
like them to the question of why them
and not others. So, we have to go
through this absurd song and dance about
stated intentional siphoning and malice
and pretend that's what was going on.
Just for calling that out, the response
was insane delusion and deflections.
Disappointing because this is unlike the
stand that Ethan took when he was sued
by the bold guy. A case which was well
worth defending and did produce good
precedent in the SDNY.
There's a few more posts here as he
argues people. Obviously, I totally
agree with what Pisk is saying there.
Totally agree with what Pisk is saying
there. would love to see um some of
these [__] losers like uh Ethan
Klein, Dan Sortman, Nicholas Dioro
uh engage with Pisco's actual statements
on this. That's what I would love to see
me personally. Or even better yet, get
into a call with him. Get into a call
with him
or me, but that sounds self-centered. So
get into Peace Guy. Okay.
[clears throat]
And for those of you who question
whether the intentional siphoning
rationale distinguishes XQC and others,
just look at what Ethan said about XQC's
conduct before. He called it intentional
siphoning, too. He It doesn't
distinguish anything. We all know the
real reason. Stop coping.
>> Why is it you you think it's crazy,
dude? The fact that you're using the
same title and the same thumbnail is so
parasitic. It's so shady. You you are
only doing that to siphon off views and
confuse people. There is no other reason
for that. Why would you use the same
exact title and the same exact
thumbnail? Explain that to me.
>> So, are you more upset about the title
or about the tone of the video itself?
>> Well, it's the intention, dude. It's all
it's all together. You're you're
intentionally confusing people to click
your video instead of his
>> since
>> So, was there any more
I want to read here? I feel like there
was one. I don't see it. Anyway, yeah,
that's the piece post. Is there anything
else I need to see before I pop up
Ethan's react?
No. Okay. All right. So, let's take a
look at this awesome
uh Casey Tron apology. That's just like
it's hilarious. Like, it's a it's like
so funny, guys. It's like a such a
[__] knee slapper, man.
They do so well with like making this
funny, like making the best out of this
moment,
you know? So, Idubbbz was totally wrong.
When Idubbbz said that [__] about about
[clears throat] this being a terrible
podcast,
he was totally wrong. He was totally
wrong. It's a great comedy podcast. The
jokes really land every time. Let's take
a look. [laughter]
And um and I just want to say that um
like I said, it's very heartfelt and
it's very meaningful and I appreciate
it. So, we're going to enjoy this here
and uh we'll watch it all together and
move on all together.
>> Mhm.
Uh oh.
Oh,
>> she can see.
>> Okay, here it is.
>> Here we go.
>> Yeah.
>> And by stating, I take responsibility
for infringing the content.
>> Yeah. Start it over.
>> I want to begin by stating I take
responsibility for infringing the
content nuke. The lawsuit was not
frivolous. When I said the lawsuit was
frivolous and based on misogyny, it was
to gar
>> So, like, who cares about what she's
saying here? It's compelled speech.
It's compelled speech. It's like you're
listening to you're sitting there
listening to uh what was it? Someone
compared it to someone about Willy Mack.
Willy M Willie Mack watches um ISIS
beheading videos and sits there going,
"Oh yeah, America America's the great
Satan. Look, the the hostage said it.
The hostage said it. America's the great
Satan. They said it. They said it.
Like, who cares what Casey Tron's saying
here? She's being forced to say it.
Like, how do you even watch this and get
anything out of it? It's meaningless.
It's just her sat there saying what
she's been told to say to not lose her
in her [__] house, you know?
Who cares?
It's just like to It means nothing. It
means nothing. It's totally worthless.
>> Sympathy, protect my own reputation.
>> It is compelled. No, it is compelled.
She doesn't have a choice. If your
choices are lose your house or read
this, it's compelled. It's compelled
>> and and retaliate against the clients.
This lawsuit has given me a greater
understanding of copyright protection,
people's copyrights, and the importance
of protecting copyrights in the online
content creation community. It is
important for the entire content
creation community to respect the
intellectual property rights of other
creators and I will adhere to the
lessons I've learned throughout this
process going forward. I also want to
make clear that I did not receive any
support.
>> Oh, so before she gets into that cuz I
love this part. Um,
[cough]
>> no it's going to stay up.
>> Oh, so then well anyway it's only three
minutes long. Um,
>> but I want to say that um I really
appreciate
she she she really
I'm [__] slapping my knee here. This
is hilarious, man. See why you see why
Zog Box and Nick Doro love this guy so
much. Can't you? He's so funny. He's so
funny and affable. This just hits, man.
This This [__] dude. I I would love
There's nothing I would love more to
than getting home, long day at work,
sitting down, you turning on YouTube.
I'm like, what am I going to look at?
What am I going to look at?
Oh, H3. My favorite show is on. H3
production. My favorite show is on.
So, yeah. So, yeah, she had to read this
or she was going to lose her house.
Isn't this funny, guys? Isn't this
funny, guys?
Wow. This This really hits. This really
hits.
This goes crazy, man. This goes crazy.
>> Great stuff. And I think that's really
important, right? Because the purpose of
this was was the activism aspect of it
all. Oh, no. I can go back. I can go
back. Oh, you know what? I should just
let it play. His number one thing was
activism, guys.
>> Enjoy certain moments of it.
>> Rich guy sits there, lies through his
teeth about how good of a guy he is
while he abuses some poor [__] [__]
on the internet and and can't keep his
decomposing body together while he
talks.
Wow. Great. Greatest show I've ever
seen, man. Greatest show I've ever seen.
Truly greatest [__] podcast of all
time.
>> Uh, or I mean not enjoy cuz certainly
that's not the right word to say, but to
appreciate.
>> Dan,
>> bring it up. Ethan just won again. Ethan
just won again.
>> You should I play it?
>> Okay, Dan wants me to play it.
>> All right, we'll start
>> slap a bunch of pasta and buy Fortnite
skins.
and by stating I take responsibility for
infringing the cont
see people being rude to her. I
genuinely
>> great
>> have forgiven her. I'm moving on and
it's water under the bridge. I don't
want to see anybody being I'm being dead
serious. Let's not be nasty to her,
guys. This is it. Okay, it's over. We
won. That's it. We won, right? So, let's
let's let's just move on. It's just so
obvious like this would not even be the
tact, but you saw it the other month he
had this whole like reckoning on stream
where he's like,
>> "Oh, Hilo wants to quit. Hilo wants to
quit." And I just feel like going going
on the attack isn't working all the
time. We have to we have to maybe try
and calm it down a bit. He he literally
like they had a whole like record where
Ela wants to quit like the entire
internet basically wants to shut down
the podcast and Ethan realizes that he
has to change tact because going
constantly on the attack and being just
like a harassment machine isn't actually
working for improving his public
reputation. It's just so transparent.
Anyone that tries to sell you this is as
genuine is like a total [__] liar
through and through.
>> Thank you
>> for infringing.
>> I'm being dead serious. Please do not.
>> The lawsuit was not frivolous. When I
said the lawsuit was frivolous and based
on misogyny, it was to garner sympathy,
protect my own reputation, and retaliate
against the clines. This lawsuit has
given me a greater understanding of
copyright protection, people's
copyrights, and the importance of
protecting copyrights in the online
content creation community. It is
important for the entire content
creation community to respect the
intellectual property rights of other
creators and I will adhere to the
lessons I've learned throughout this
process going forward. I also want to
make clear that I did not receive any
support financial or otherwise from
Hassan [__] Hassan never even reached
out to me privately to offer words of
support. Speaking honestly, I found his
indifference to my suffering. Oh, see
it's just like so embarrassing because
it's so obvious to play here. It's like,
oh, Hassan donates money. Oh, Casey
Strong, go out there and say that I I'll
be giving all the money Hassan gave me
to Ethan so we can epically own Hassan.
Hassan doesn't donate money. Oh,
Hassan's such a fake social. He doesn't
even help his friends out.
It's so It's so transparent and lame.
It's like these people are literally the
most despicable [__] dishonest
retards going. It's so transparent that
it's not even like ideologically
motivated half the time. It's basically
like there's a bunch of fat dudes on the
internet like Nick Dioro who didn't get
laid in college, probably got mocked by
all their fat bros and told to go [__]
with hot girls and then they laughed at
them when he got rejected in front of
them. Got ab, you know, absolutely
[__] nothing going for him. And so he
just [__] sees that all these
roasties in college love Hassan so much.
They're all Hassan fans. We need to
kill. That's B. That's the thought
process. That's how they think about it.
That's how they came to these positions.
Nick doesn't understand any of the
politics, so it certainly wasn't some,
you know, thoughtful, moral, or
philosophical conclusion.
Hurtful, especially after he hinted he
might help me behind the scenes. It felt
like he [laughter] wanted to receive
credit from the public for helping me
without providing any.
As to the GoFundMe money, to the extent
there are any remaining funds after I
pay my attorney's fees, I have agreed to
pay the remaining funds to the clients.
The funds will not go any
>> Can we acknowledge that Ethan and
everything he does on his stream is the
most anti-Semitic trope ever. Yes. Yes.
We we've acknowledged that many times.
We've acknowledged that many times.
>> Anyone else, including Denims or Frogan,
to defend their lawsuits? For the
record, I have agreed to cooperate with
the clients in their litigation against
the H3 Snark Mods for promoting my live
stream to the extent that I am able. I
will offer my support, including
testifying under oath to everything I
have just stated to help their cause. I
also want to take the opportunity to
acknowledge other misconduct and bad
behavior I have exhibited online. For
example, weaponizing the death the death
of Asmin Gold's mother was inexcusable.
I should know better because I have
three disabled people that rely on me.
Moving forward, I will do better. I also
want to apologize to the crew of the H3
podcast.
>> Yeah, apologize to Aspen Gold. Yeah,
apologize to Asmin Gold, bro. Well, what
an epic win. What an epic win. Whoa.
This is This is totally a principled
position and not just Ethan throwing red
meat to a bunch of just like scumb [__]
on the internet that have helped him out
with his gay little war.
particularly AB and Olivia.
>> Yeah,
>> I apologize for calling them cowards for
not quitting their jobs. That was a
shameful attack on two people who deeply
care about Palestine and Palestinian
people.
>> True.
>> AB along with his wife Lena
have ever done for the Palestinian
people, including raising over $100,000
in charity. Yeah,
>> I recognize that they have actually made
Palestinian lives better and my online
antagonism and trolling has not.
>> Loner Box's chat was saying this wasn't
just directed by Ethan. Dude, people are
literally so [__]
How do they not like like how does
someone like Lo Box just look around and
go like, "Dude, what the [__] is going
on? How have I how have I seriously like
you have to overlook so much. If I see
one person going like he's saying some
[__] [__] in my chat, I might freak
out. Like, why the [__] are you even
watching me? [__] you. Leave. [__] you.
Leave.
>> Yeah.
>> I apologize to Ethan and Hila
personally. I have said extremely mean
and cruel things about both of them,
particularly my misogynistic attacks
against Hila that never should have been
said. I also want to acknowledge the
pervasive problem of anti-semitism in
leftist spaces. It should concern all of
us. I condemn it and will not
participate in it. To that end, I wish
the client's success in enforcing TED
Entertainment's copyright and protecting
the legal rights of online content
creators.
>> Wow. [snorts]
>> Just sit on that for a sec. Just
[snorts]
>> so he doesn't even have like a like a
joke or something to land this with. He
says just sit on that for a sec. Let's
pause for a fact. So, you're just going
to sit there for a minute. Wow. Great
stuff, mate. Wow. Awesome comedy
podcast.
Let me check my phone here. Sit on that.
You know, just just take it all in.
>> Dude, I I I watched uh some of Nick's
coverage, like I said, and it's funny.
Chud watched way more of this than than
Nick did. Nick can't even pretend to
enjoy these. Nick can't even pretend to
enjoy this show. It's so funny. He
literally he will he'll only watch like
a little bit because he literally can't
even pretend to actually enjoy when
they're sitting there trying to be
funny. It's it's it's hilarious. But he
has to he has to be like in the in the
house. he has to be in the house. It's
just so crazy. And he just like, you
know, you see him sitting there and he's
just like making the lamest jokes that
like barely make sense, you know, when
he's basically just doing, you know,
Nick does like jokes that are basic like
word association into pop culture
reference where it like doesn't actually
quite fit with the situation at all.
He's just sort of like trying to fit in
like, you know, just like zogged out
references or whatever the [__] he's
like doing that repeatedly while
watching this and going
you know, like like he does. And uh
yeah, it's just very funny. It's just
very funny watching him like try and
make something of it.
He just like just keeps screaming like,
"Get [__] bitch." And all this sort of
[__] over and over again. He makes this
really cringe joke as well, dude. Oh,
man. We might go over this bit. I I I
only really want to go over his Denim's
tweet response because that's where he
really he really puts his foot in his
mouth. Um but there's one there's one
moment he's just like he does like this
impression, dude. He does like an
impression of well I guess it's meant to
be like a
like oldtimey
like um
talent agent type character telling
telling a girl to smile more and calling
her Tootss and it just sent shivers down
my spine listening to this man.
It sent shivers down my spine hearing
it. I was like, "Dude, there's no way
you think that's funny." You know,
there's no way you thought you were
funny that was funny to that. It was,
bro, it was rough. It was rough. It was
rough. It was He sounded like a rapist,
but not in the way cuz obviously he's
trying to sound sort of show like
chauvinistic and oldfashioned, but not
in that way. That's the thing. He
sounded
like a like lacking the r to even do
that jokingly and coming off like a
rapist basically.
It was rough. It was It was really bad.
It was really bad. I'm genuinely
traumatized from watching that [__]
clip earlier.
Anyway, let's uh let's finish this
Ethan.
>> Look at it, you know. It just
just sit on it.
What a what a heartfelt
I mean like gen genuinely and I'm going
to be I'm going to say something Casey
Tron we've said it continually
throughout this you are extraordinarily
funny
>> and a very talented person and I wish
you all the best in the future in your
future endeavors and I know you will
continue to make people laugh and to um
and to continue to to bring joy to In
that regard, I do I think you're you're
you are extremely funny and very clever.
So, [snorts]
>> and and I accept your apology. I do
comedy podcast
and just all the specific comedy
podcast.
>> A lot of the stuff in there was was
really I think warranted and and I'm
glad that she's, you know,
come to terms with a lot of it and I
appreciate it. They really think she's
>> remember this guy used to make videos
where he just like he was just like, you
know, calling like some black music
producer a pedophile. Go. Let's go back
to that. Let's go back to that.
>> The new leave. I do [applause]
that. Now, let's watch it then. Now I
can pause it and stuff. Right.
>> Now that we've watched it, you can do
whatever you want.
>> All right. So
now the part one part that really stands
out to me is the part about Hassan
because he really did make it and we
have that clip right of when Hassan was
making
>> part of this statement that I wrote that
really stands out to me
>> like [laughter]
[snorts]
um
>> can we watch that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. When Hassan was making it
sound like he [snorts] was going to help
them and and I mean rightfully so. If I
was him, I would have reached out
immediately and offered my support uh
emotionally and financially, right?
>> And then that is something I have done
uh you know on in other instances.
>> It's incredibly stressful both
emotionally and financially to go
through a lawsuit.
>> It is and I appreciate the the the
situation she's been in and that's why
>> dude, let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go, man. Let's go. Let's go. Let's
go. Alex Neville said that saying that
Ethan melted down in DMs with him today
and there's a full video coming soon.
And these these are some of the texts. I
gave you my number because I trusted
you, brother. You don't have permission
to share this private conversation
either. Just to prove to you it's not a
gotcha. I wouldn't waste my time texting
with you if it was just for a gotcha.
>> Um
>> which is also why I'm so glad to at
least put one behind us.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And I know it was difficult on her and
I'm glad that she's that she's free of
it now and she can just move on. We can
all move on. I really do. I my heart I I
I have appreciation
for Casey.
>> Dude, dude, dude. What if I just saw
someone saying, "What if Dan got Alex
Noel in contact with Ethan?" You know
how Dan in that call in the Destiny
video was like,
"Oh, I can get you on I can get you on
Redact." And Alex is Alex is like
telling him he's a Jew and all this
[__]
He's like, "Oh, I'm Jewish, by the way.
I'm Jewish, by the way."
[snorts] Dude, that'd be so funny if
Dan's actually that if if Dan is
actually that that easy. If Dan is
actually that much of a mark. It's
literally just the the ingroup bias
every time. The inroup bias every time.
That's how everyone everyone gets down
on side.
>> Tran.
and I thank her very much for the for
the very uh thorough and sincere
apology. That [snorts] being said, let's
watch this clip of when Hassan suggests
he will be helping them behind the
scenes.
>> He has also admitted multiple times he
wants to hurt you financially through
them as if you were their legal
guardian. No, I know. I know. I have
never suggested that by the way or well
[laughter]
maybe well I did maybe did suggest that
he should help them which he should
I mean they're his orbiters right now
>> it's just like honestly
what what are Hassan's plays here I feel
like it's the right play to just you
know not donate basically if he was
going to take the money if that was a
likely outcome why would you
>> and Hassan is extraordinarily [__] and
facts saying um [snorts]
yeah in case it wasn't like Hassan told
Casey Tron to go do this stupid [__]
either
like Casey Trron had the weakest case
out of any of the three people being
sued
and he didn't tell us go do this stupid
[__] he didn't say oh Casey would be a
really good idea if you went live on
Twitch and just sat there and watch
Ethan Klein's video in total [__]
silence smoking weed the whole time
did he you know like so what [__]
obligation would he possibly have to
help Caseyron outs sad
>> saying he just sits on a pile of cash
like the dragon.
>> Yeah. He sat on leftovers. He just
>> I go, "What do you do with your
fortune?" He
>> just sits there.
>> He goes, "I just sit on it."
>> Yeah.
>> I was like, "Okay, SMG the dragon. You
don't have any [__] better uses than
just sitting on a pile of gold."
>> Yeah. I got to stop.
>> Anyway, [snorts] so here's what he said.
>> That's why he keeps saying like, "Oh,
socialist. Why won't he give these guys
money?" Trust me, if I if I offer
support
>> Well, apparently socialism is when you
don't give people money because as a
capitalist myself and as and a liberal
de democrat, I would absolutely
>> Well, I mean, socialism isn't when you
give people money. So, this is like the
[__] thing that people do. I
understand like wanting Hassan to do
more that's in line with his ideology
and saying it doesn't really seem like
you're that committed to it. I get that.
Um just the constant, oh, Hassan, you
didn't give money in this case. Do you
really no money in this case? So I don't
do a socialist. It's so [__] stupid.
Socialism is about giving money.
Socialism is about worker ownership,
right? It's about worker ownership or
the means of production. That's what
Assan talks about.
It's not just about, oh, I'm a
socialist, so that means I give you
$100.
I'm a socialist, so I'm giving out $100
to everyone I see today. It's not what
it means. That's not what it means.
give them money. I pay all my employees,
you know what I mean? My mods, [snorts]
everybody gets paid around here. I don't
ask anybody to work for free. That is a
uniquely socialistic uh philosophy. It
seems like
it's actually not remotely socialist at
all, Ethan. You're a capitalist. Paying
your employees,
paying employees does not make you a
socialist. I don't know. Where where is
this analysis even coming from? What's
this even like? What is the idea here?
What are we talking about?
>> Like at least from Hassan's POV.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's Hassan's version of
socialism.
>> He's paying employees. Yeah.
>> I thought Hassan was a radical tanky. I
thought he's like an ML.
>> I thought he's like an ML hiding his
power level and he tricked you. Now
you're saying that Hassan thinks that
socialism is just when you give out some
money when you're rich. So what's the
fearongering about, Ethan? What's the
fearongering about?
is I get paid a a mountain of coins to
sit and guard on and you get nothing.
>> I hate all of you.
[clears throat]
>> You won't know about it. Okay.
>> It's just like so [__]
[snorts]
>> So you see like like the implication
there is pretty heavy.
>> Yeah.
>> And he even gives like let me go back
cuz the Oh [__] it's so long. Hold on.
Let me I forgot it's like a seven hour
>> clip. Let me reopen it to the time stamp
because there is some important stuff.
>> Oh, it means working for free is winning
out. Ethan, it's smoo.
>> That still doesn't make any sense.
>> You say smog.
>> No, I said I literally went out of my
way to say smog.
>> Okay. Well, then
>> run it back with the chatters.
>> Pick it up with the chatters
>> because because I knew people were going
to be geared up to call me out for that
and I went out of my way to pronounce it
right. Pull it back.
>> No, I believe you. I believe you. I
believe you. these chatters. They're
wilding.
>> Dude,
I do want to continue to emphasize, be
nice to Casey Tron. We [snorts] won. She
apologized. That's it.
>> I'm seeing a lot of love for her in
chat. A+ a
>> Okay, let's get the Hassan reaction to
the settlement next. I think we're done
with the Ethan Vaude. Ethan is totally
totally unwatchable. Even more so than
Hassan somehow. She
>> doesn't say stuff about you. Oh,
awesome. Is she done?
Is it over? Will she no longer be
haunted by
the H3 H3 podcast?
Right. I hope she said I suck.
I don't give a [__]
She settled
and threw you under the bus kind of.
What do you mean under what bus?
Something about your indifference, but
whatever. We should talk about this to
be honest. People are [__] if they
think a song gives a [__] that she said
that [__]
>> He's obviously not going to give a [__]
His perspective is going to be, "Yeah,
get out of it with the least money given
to Ethan possible."
Right. I I assume that's going to be his
perspective.
She should went harder. You think I give
a [__] I want this I want this legal
bullying to end. You can say whatever
the [__] you want about me. If it's
gonna get Ethan Klein off your ass, go
ahead.
She said she she had to say you said you
will help but did not help at all and
just use it to make yourself popular.
That's what they demanded in the
settlement. That's so [__] sad.
But hey, yeah. No, that's right. I'm a
bad person.
You can say whatever the [__] you want
about how much of a [__] douchebag I
am, how much you hate me in your uh in
your settlement negotiations. If Ethan
Klein is up your [__] crawling up
your [__] hell yeah.
Say I'm a bad guy. Say I'm anti-semitic.
Say I'm an anti-semitic terrorist.
You think I give a [__] What are you
crazy?
Yeah. I want this I want this [__] uh
insane
I want this insane torment to end.
>> So, what's the cope about this clip?
What's the cope about this clip? How How
do I If I wanted to do a segment right
now where I'm behaving like a fat
[__] stupid ass [__] What? How
would I criticize this clip? What would
I say about it? What would I say about
it? I'm glad that um
I'm glad that Caseyron no longer has to
deal with this [__] nightmare.
>> He admitted to being anti-semitic.
>> They made her say anti-semitism is on
the rise in the left. Pretty vile
people. I mean, I don't think a single
person that looks at this statement is
going to be like, "Wow, this you say
cope again and again. You just say cope
again and again."
But I don't think this is cope. I think
he I think he genuinely means he doesn't
care if you have to say
he's a piece of [__] to get out of some
[__] lawsuit with Ethan Klein. I
don't I don't think he
I don't I don't think that's hiding some
belief that he actually really does
care.
>> Written apology. No, they're going to
[__] be
>> lazy. Just go cope cope cope. They can
do about anything.
>> Well, since this is brought up, they
made her apologize to Asmin Gold, too.
This shit's got to stop.
again. Great.
If you are getting your rocks off off of
basically trying to bankrupt
a random person online,
uh, so much so that they might become
homeless and you make them shoot an ISIS
style hostage video in the process of
mediator and that's how he can get your
rocks off. You are one of the biggest,
most pathetic losers of all [__]
time. torturing small streamers to get
your [__] rocks off.
>> Wait, wait. I've got it. I've got it.
I've got it. I've got it. I've got it.
>> Hassan, if it's an ISIS beheading video,
why aren't you reacting to it on stream
with NP wall?
>> Am I doing it right, guy? Is that it? Is
that Is that
loser that you are? Congratulations. You
got your [__] legmandated
courtmandated apology. And it wasn't
even to serve any sort of justice
whatsoever. It was because you had a lot
of [__] money. You had a lot more
money than they did so you could bury
them in a mountain of paperwork.
Okay.
No, you're in the right, dude. Everybody
knows that's what that's what real
winners do.
And the reality of the matter is, yeah,
by the way, Ethan is literally behaving
like Israel. This is like Israel style
behavior. But the reality of the matter
is if anyone actually looks at that, if
anyone actually looks at any of those
statements,
>> see that's [__] [__] really, isn't it?
So, and I should hear Nick react to this
part. Nick said, "Oh, wow. Mask off.
That's not mask off." He should have
said Ethan's behaving like an
anti-semitic caricature.
Cuz that's what should that is the
actual truth.
He's behaving like a caricature of an
evil latigious Jew. He's not behaving
like Israel because he's not he's not
killed anyone
or any kids yet whatsoever and turns
around and says, "Wow,
um this is, you know, justice has been
served here. They're already a [__]
loser, too." The funniest part about
this is the idea that like Hassan used
this to promote himself and is and and
maintain popularity. Yeah, it was a real
popular thing,
especially amongst the biggest [__]
losers on the internet.
Are you worried he will ever try to sue
you?
>> I'm coming up with I'm coming up with a
new unique
handrobing motion that we will be using
to imitate Ethan Klein. Guys, it's
called the the Ethan Klein. When you're
scheming, when you're thinking about
suing people, when you're scheming and
thinking about suing people and lying
about why you're doing it, you can do
the Ethan kind by rubbing your hands
together. [laughter]
>> The [__] would I be worried that he
would try to sue me? What can he sue me
over?
Nothing.
>> No, he's trying to sue whoever he can
that he can bury in a mountain of
[__] paperwork.
>> If anything makes them look bad is the
most forced thing I've ever seen.
Exactly.
Yeah. What's he going to do? Defame me
and then sue me for not suing him for
defamation? What are we talking about?
Yeah, he's going to sue me for not
watching the content nuke after he
begged me.
Wow. Okay, there's the Hassan reaction.
Now, now, now, now. Let's find my
archive of this [__] [__] stream.
This total [__] inbredad. Okay,
so let's watch Nick
read the statement. Okay, let's watch
Nick read and respond to this statement.
So, he's going to go over the Denim's
Twitter post about this. I'm not going
to read it myself because Nick's going
to do it. And you'll just see there's a
few funny moments in here and moments
where this guy sticks his foot in his
mouth or totally overextends on stupid
[__] that he has no idea what he's
talking about. Let's have a look. I
would love to see Nick I would love to
see Nick if he ever, you know, catch
wind. I would love to see Nick react to
any of the peace code coverage or
statements on this. Okay, actually
engage with it because it's great.
There's good legal opinions out there
that totally refute the stupid [__] you
keep saying about this. So your feigned
ignorance is not a [__] excuse. You
disgusting [__] low life,
>> dude. This is so good. This is so
[__] good,
>> dude. She's the hero of YouTube right
now. We have to defend her at all costs.
[music] Hold on.
This is Denim's response to Casey Tron's
legal rebuttal. This apology, which I
can only assume was somehow forced to
extract a settlement, was painful to
listen to. It's absurd and ironic that
Ethan accuses Hassan of being a
puppeteer while laring as a comic book
villain in this way.
>> Slop roy music. While it's unfortunate
that Ethan appears to have been able to
exert control over her in this way, I am
happy that Caseyron was given an
opportunity to minimize the harm to her
family and avoid the risk of losing her
home and move on from Ethan's lawsuit.
>> Okay. Problem where?
>> I want to make several things clear. My
trial date is [music] 10:26 26 and I
look forward to beating Ethan in court
while Casey and likely Froggen have
caved to
what
>> see you see what you have to do to be
Nick Dioro. You see how every moment of
this guy's life is just waking [__]
dishonesty. It's just like constant
dishonesty. He like the most despicable
worthless [__] low life. It's so
obvious. You've already all clocked it.
I assume what's about to happen. He
goes, "What? What? Did she just leak
that Froggen is is abandoning her
lawsuit?" Says likely Frogan as in she
probably doesn't know. Nick, likely
Froggen. What does likely mean? Nick,
you've been following these cases. Nick,
you've been following this story. You
should know that Frogan hasn't responded
to any of the motions in the lawsuit.
Apparently, she got served or arguably
got served and basically hasn't
responded.
So, yeah, it seems like that's the case.
Likely Froggen, you should know that
because you covered the story, but no,
you have to be dishonest in every moment
of your life. You you haven't seen
anything in the first paragraph that you
can make a big deal out of. So, the the
worry is kind of kicking in. I've read
half of this statement and I haven't
like gone, "Oh my god, cope, cope, cope,
cope." I haven't done that yet. So, I
need to find something to make a big
deal out of. Very blatant, very obvious,
very dishonest individual. Very, very
dishonest individual. What do you mean
and likely Frogan?
Wait. Whoa.
>> Whoa.
>> Whoa. Wait. When did That's news to me.
That's news to me. Is Frogan settling?
>> This is subhuman.
>> Did you just leak that Frogan will be
settling?
While Casey and likely Froggen have
caved to Ethan Klein, which is a
decision I doubt they have made lightly,
settling like this is not an option for
me. It is not an option for me because
it would set a precedent that endangers
the financial scrutiny of any streamer
that creates reaction content. No, it
doesn't. It literally threatens people
who do not create reaction content.
>> It literally just [__] threatens
people who steal content over at Twitch.
We've been telling you this for years,
okay? My content is not in any [__]
danger if if you lose this [__]
lawsuit. All right. Do you ever react to
a full video? He does. He likes to say
now he's trying to like um
alter his sort of like uh uh points that
he makes about copyright a little bit.
You might have noticed if you watch a
few of his streams, he started altering
stuff. He says now that he doesn't watch
full videos. He does watch full videos.
He's watched full videos many times.
Absolutely many times. only since this
stuff happened because this can endanger
full video reactions, any full video
reaction because Denims did
substantively critique and respond to
the Ethan Klein content nuke. In fact,
she did more reaction than many other
content creators and she didn't say, not
that this matters to any of the legal
analysis. I'm maliciously siphoning
views as she goes over here. Nick's
going to try and cope around that, but
we'll see that in a minute.
But that doesn't, but even if she did,
doesn't matter to the legal analysis.
It's [__] irrelevant. It's [__]
irrelevant. It doesn't It doesn't matter
whether she said she was doing it
maliciously or not. It's not about
whether you say you're creating a market
replacement. It's about whether you
create a market replacement.
So, just saying that's why I can say I'm
making a market replacement for for um
[__] man Coca-Cola.
And I just like pour some sugar in water
and bottle it and sell it. No one's
going to be like, "Oh, you've just
created a market replacement for
Coca-Cola. You just stole their You
stole that's a patented. That's patented
and you just stole it." No one's going
to say that because it's not a market
replacement. It's so [__] stupid.
You threaten my ability to make content
by consistently posting garbage, calling
it reaction content, and being placed in
a similar conversation as streamers like
me. All right. I am not like
>> how does that threaten your ability to
make reaction content? Let's let's try
and this is the closest thing to an
argument of how that might work of this
genuinely threatening his ability to do
reaction content
through some tiny contribution drop in
the bucket contribution. Denim slightly
moves the needle in an ever so tiny tiny
infotimal fashion that a single person
can in a broad political environment
ever slightly moves the needle on
people's feelings about copyright
broadly and then later on down the line
as a court judgment is made as a piece
of legislation is introduced as
something big happens politically denim
has had a tiny tiny infantestimal
contribution towards that that change
and you no longer can do reaction
content that's how that would happen how
does how does Ethan threaten reaction
content well he's first of all uh done a
deceptive uh trick where he has
registered a piece of content with the
Library of Congress so that you can try
and get statutory copyright infringement
um
uh get liability for statuto copyright
infringement. So he's done a deceptive
tactic there that he's introduced that
we haven't seen before that that he's
introduced that he's made now a tactic
he's made precedent for. So that's step
one. Step two, if one of these cases
goes to the end and they lose, there
could be a precedent setting decision
that says that reaction content isn't
allowed or that full length reactions
aren't allowed, something that will
cause problems because for a long time
people have said you should actually
watch the whole video, especially if
it's political like the content nuke was
because you want to hear their arguments
in full. You don't want to take stuff
out of context. You want to respond to
the arguments in full, which obviously
if people reacted to parts of the
content nuke, people would have said,
"Oh, you're cherry-picking. You haven't
reacted to it in full." Additionally,
Dennis is being sued for a piece of
content that critiqued her. She's
critiqued in the content nuke for a
non-significant amount of time. So,
she's critiqued in the content nuke. She
reacts to criticism of her and she is
sued for it. Okay? So, that can affect
it. And that's ignoring all the stuff
from the Caseyron uh situation we've
already just had. where there is now a
precedent set where if you don't like
the stuff someone's saying about you,
you go after them for copyright and then
you can essentially compel a statement
from them saying that you won, saying
that, oh, you were writing the drama the
whole time. Something that should
concern a commentary YouTuber. But I
guess Nick has totally forgotten all
those principles that he used to espouse
so [__] heavily in like every video
on his channel.
So there you go, Nick. That that might
help you out a bit. I recommend watching
some of Pisco's coverage. I recommend
maybe even talking to Pisco. That might
be a bit a bit too much to ask from Nick
though. Way too much to ask from Nick. I
think that would be a good idea. I think
that would be good. I think if he looked
at Pisco's content, if he had any
disagreements, he can maybe maybe say,
"Oh, I want to debate this lawyer about
the impacts of this this legal case."
That that'd be interesting. I think that
would be interesting. That would be an
extreme that I would tune in for unlike
most of them. I usually get other people
to do it for me. Let's keep watching.
>> Like you and I'm staying as far away
from you as humanly possible. If Denims
wins this lawsuit, we're in like
literally we're going back to the Wild
West. You can do [__] anything.
Literally anything can be done. You can
react to literally anything and not
actually react to it. Just walk away
from the [__] camera probably.
>> So that's not what Denims did. That's
not what Denims did. Denims did
substantively react to the content.
if Denims wins this lawsuit, which
again, despite the fact that I make
content where I react to videos on
stream and give my thoughts on it, I
don't want people to just be able to
>> The Wild West would be better
>> everything uh especially my own content.
So,
if you create content that involves
commenting on videos on Twitch or
enjoying
>> I don't what you don't want people to be
able to archive stuff, Nick. You don't
think archives are a good thing? Didn't
Nick, didn't you spend like half your
career crying on behalf of Bo Blacks
because he was getting struck down for
doing full reuploads of other people's
content?
Isn't like half your career crying about
that, Nick? Assuming reaction content,
you should be on my side. [music] If you
don't believe me, please read ahead and
let me convince you. I watched in
reaction [music] to Ethan's highly
anticipated content shortly after it
>> aired Nick Oreo. Make no mistake, my
coverage more than doubled Ethan's video
in length. [music] Ethan's video spanned
roughly 104 minutes. I spent 230 minutes
reacting to, [music]
critiquing, and commenting on his video
and the content in it during which I
>> praise for this. Okay, key number there.
minutes. Okay guys, 230
minutes. That's what 3 hours 50 I
believe. 3 hours 50 would be 240 for for
4 hours. So 3 hours 50 we've got there.
Denim's reaction
>> 210 times. That means I added 120% of
the run time in commentary on average
pausing every 30 seconds to add 36
seconds of commentary. Now I'm not
facteing this. I'm going to assume that
she's telling the truth here. I remember
watching her video on my stream. You can
actually watch my reaction to Denims
because I did react to her viewing of it
and it was literally just like she'll go
on a random tangent about something that
has nothing to do with the video or
she'll hear Ethan say a sentence and
then go on like remember this one time
kind of things. So despite that she's
saying that I don't think that she added
130 minutes of actual content to
>> that is yes that is literally Nick does
this Nick does this for huge amounts of
his reactions. Huge amounts of it.
They're just impausing to make
irrelevant go references, go on a
tangent about some old drama. That's the
huge amount of this guy's content.
That's how he gets runtime. He doesn't
talk about the topic. Oftent times he
does everything he can to avoid actually
addressing the key disagreements on the
topic because he knows that he's going
to contradict himself if he does. That's
huge amounts of his reaction content to
the Ethan stuff. You can go back and
watch it if you think that's untrue. you
can just go back and watch. It's
blatantly true. It happens all the time.
So, it's crazy for Nick to do this
nitpicking of, "Oh, well, you say you
pause for 36 seconds for every 30
seconds of content, but a lot of those
times you're actually just talking about
Avengers Endgame."
Oh, yeah.
Do it. As much as she might have paused
and talked to chat or thanked somebody
for something.
Also,
why are you tweeting this?
Why are you posting this on TW? That's a
good question. I just read that from
chat. Why are you tweeting this?
Why are you tweeting your court defense?
>> These are publicly available facts and
Denims has already filed her reply to
Ethan's initial motion. Right.
Denims has already replied. So, a lot of
a lot of I believe some of this is
already laid out.
>> That's really stupid. This is like Carl
Jobs the end
substantially more than
>> this is just like this is just like
Boax. This is just like this is just
like um Aiden. This is like tipster
>> XQC or many of the other streamers and
YouTubers [music] that watch the content
nuke in full. Is that longer than mine?
Well, mine's cut down.
>> So, let's try and figure this out. So,
remember guys, 230 minutes. 230 minutes.
Remember that guys.
>> The original length. What was my content
nuke reaction on YouTube? Um, it's
probably longer than
>> just started insulting me viciously on
Twitter.
>> Let's see the word nuke if I can spell
correctly. Nuke my content nuke video.
No, that's not even it. Which one is it?
Um,
final word. Total loser. Which one was
it? April. March. I recommend watching
Nicholas Dioro's latest video.
>> Let's see.
What month was I post so many [__]
videos. Let me just look in the Ethan
Klein playlist.
Oh, wait. I have a content nuke
playlist, don't I?
I have so many playlists. Holy [__]
dude.
YouTube Drama Content Deputy Creator
Clash 3.
Um,
the debate content cop age H3. Did I not
make a playlist for the nuke?
Let me see. Mike from PA replied to
this. Good, dude. That's That's exactly
what I needed.
>> Nuke
the $5.
>> Okay. Yeah, here it is.
>> Nick thinks trials are spontaneous
debates between lawyers that have hidden
their arguments, evidence, etc. from one
another.
>> Thank you for the o $5. Okie dokie.
Thank you.
>> Mine. Oh, Jesus Christ, dude. I stay
[__] winning, bro. I stay [__]
winning. It took me three hours to watch
this.
[laughter]
So, two 230 minutes, remember?
230 minutes.
>> Oh my god, dude. Holy [__] Yeah, I'm
not I don't feel threatened by denims at
all. I don't feel
>> This is 3 hours 16. The other one's 230
minutes. I'll let you do the conversions
in your head. I but nothing about
Denim's lawsuit is scaring me. Holy
[__] dude. I did over three hours in
that video now, dude. So, nothing about
Denim's lawsuit is scaring me. Now, the
first reason why it doesn't scare him is
because half of her commentary was
irrelevant. She's just like talking
about Avengers Endgame or like old [__]
that happened like, "Oh, remember this
time?" So, half of it's just commentary
like that. And then the other thing is
her reaction was so short. Her reaction
was so short. So, this isn't worrying
Nick at all cuz this would never apply
to him for these argument. Because of
these reasons that he's just laid out
because of these reasons that he's just
laid out. This would never apply to him.
Two and two hours and wait 230 minutes
is [__] 120% of the run time. That's
crazy, bro.
Um,
well, no, wait, hold on. [laughter]
No, actually did she I think she did
more.
>> She did 230 minutes reacting to it
>> then hers is 304 minutes.
>> Is that just the time that she spent
there? So if she like paused to talk
about something random, is she just
including that as well?
>> Yeah, she actually did more. That's
crazy.
>> So he literally he doesn't even realize.
So the video is 230 minutes, right? The
video is is 3 hours 50, right? The video
is 3 hours 50. The whole reaction with
the with the content you 3 hours 50.
Okay. 230 minutes. Nick says my 3hour 15
video would be longer.
However, you have to add the 230
minutes of Denim's reaction to the 104
minutes of the original video to achieve
304 minutes, which then actually makes
it longer than 3 hours 15, guys. That
actually then makes it longer than 3
hours 15. You see, how do you just do
this night off some [__] like this?
cuz we covered. Where's the denims one?
I gave up on that. What was that
actually?
Hold on.
>> Dioro math. I want to call it something
else. I was going to say something else.
I was going to say something else. I'm
killing my Twitch stream.
>> I probably don't have that many Denims
videos.
>> [__] math.
>> Five months ago. Five months ago.
>> I had to eight months ago. That's his
position.
>> Is it this one? Like moving? No, that's
that's her rebuttal.
>> Nine months ago. Okay. Yeah, this one.
We watched her for like an hour
>> is earning the coveted
>> video. I'm gonna start my toy show
again.
>> Oh, and then we put in all the eap clips
and stuff.
>> Proven wrong. Let's watch.
>> No, this isn't even I don't
>> This drama is so [__] long.
>> Holy [__]
>> Where is it? [laughter]
>> Length is substantially more than Asmin
Gold XQC or many of the other streamers
and YouTubers who watch the content nuke
in full. As we know, Ethan decided not
to sue Asmin Gold, XQC,
[laughter]
>> uh, or anyone other than the three of
us, but he wouldn't sue them. They
didn't intentionally try to deprive him
of revenue, and you said yourself that
you did. This notion [laughter] is
frivolous and a fabrication. Ethan
claims that he's pursuing this claim
against me because someone claimed
malicious intent on my part. There are
two statements of Ethan falsely claiming
>> insulting me viciously on Twitter
>> that demonstrate my intent along with
his conspiracy theory about collusion
with moderators, none of whom I've ever
communicated with. So this is just her
response publicly
for the lawsuit. This is so weird.
[laughter]
>> Asmin Gold didn't watch the entire
video.
Um
the first statement is my response to a
chat message I read out loud. We were uh
relying on you staying live so we don't
have to give it views and then replying,
"Yeah, I'm going to stream it."
Wait, how is that meaningfully
different?
Because it's just it's a it's an
off-handed response to a chat message,
not a statement of intent. Her intent
was to respond to the video. Someone
said they wanted to watch it there and
she said, "Yeah, I'll be streaming."
It's not a statement of an intent to
create a market replacement. Not that
that matters. Once again, not that that
matters to the legal analysis. Wouldn't
matter to the president,
>> dude. Yeah. So, thank god I get to watch
your content so I don't have to watch it
on his channel.
>> Pizza, dude.
>> Oh, yeah. Don't worry, I'll be live. Oh,
okay. Yeah, that's that's very
different. I hope this is self-evident,
but it would be bizarre for me to take
that opportunity to bring attention to
this group of people [music]
uh and how they should actually watch
the video on his channel. It's not my
place. I don't care. and making a big
deal out of it would only encourage the
zealatry that Ethan is upset about. I
merely acknowledged that I was going to
react to it and moved on. Drawing a
broader narrative based on a chat
message I did not write is delusional.
The second statement is a throwaway
shill comment I said after the video
before signing off. Well guys, if you
enjoyed not giving any views to that
terrible video, follow Oh my god, dude.
How are you defending this right now? Do
you
>> Oh my Oh my god, how are you defending
this? Dude, how many times I guarantee
we could find a clip of Nick saying
basically that exact thing. Even his
Even your friend Nick has said this.
Everyone says [__] like that. Everyone
[__] says [__] like that. Everyone says
[__] like that. When they get done
watching a video that everyone hated.
Everyone says [__] like that. Oh my god.
How are you defending this? How are you
defending this? It's a very common sort
of statement. It's actually very common
in streaming to say something like that.
>> This Do you believe this statement?
If someone watched my coverage, they had
no interest in watching Ethan's video
without the additional critical
commentary and never would have. How the
[__] would you know? This is like a
longstanding react rape content [__]
[laughter]
How would you know? Well, obviously
she's saying that because that is part
of her legal defense. She believes that
to be the case is making that as part of
a legal defense.
>> Quan, were you saying that Nick acts and
looks like the Peter Griffin of
commentary? Oh [snorts] jeez. This is
just like the time salibidi sent lemon
party to a 12year-old. Then a slam cut
to ah.
Thank you for the $10, Jimbo. Thank you.
Thank you, Jimbo.
>> This is literally, dude, this is like a
Dark Viper react rape essay. Uh, talking
point. This is This is some [__] that I
would hear Dark Viper start crying
about.
>> Regardless, this statement is not
characterized by intent. At most, you
can say this is a meaningless comment
for Well, I don't think he viewed it as
a meaningless comment. I don't think he
think he thinks that at all. Yeah.
>> Making a joke about this is too far that
Ethan Klein deserves more respect. We
could agree to disagree. I humbly
request we take this opportunity to qu
uh question Ethan's framing of events
and call a spade a spade. Ethan is
bullying people who said things about
him that he did not like and he can do
that only because he has more money than
them. In doing so, at least his lawsuit
against me,
>> he is setting a disastrous precedent for
our corner of the internet. Yeah, not
likely. And my hope is that
>> so I mean Nick feel free to go and look
at Pisco's legal analysis on this stuff.
>> Others in this community with resources
like Ethan's do not follow in his small
footsteps. Please donate to my legal
fund. Every penny donation has gone
exclusively to court costs and fees and
will go nowhere else. As stated earlier,
my trial date is 102. Guy who relates
everything to Encyclopedia Dramatica.
>> Ideally with your assistance, thank you
for the attention on this matter. So,
she's begging for more money, which I
mean is her best bet right now. But I
think the people are going to be a bit
more hesitant to send their money to
Ethan. I mean, to Denims. I will argue
that the little I do know about the
legal aspect to this. I imagine Denims
has a significantly stronger case than
Casey Tron. I think Casey Tron was
legitimately [__] So, I'm not
surprised that Casey immediately bows
out.
>> Wow. I'm not I'm also not surprised that
she's trying to use this as an
opportunity to like get mad.
>> Okay, I did I didn't watch past this
point, so I'm not going to sit here and
just watch a bunch of Nick stuff cuz I
truly find this guy so [__] boring.
However, I do want to try and find that
clip I was talking about where he makes
the the Toots joke cuz I want to show
you how much of a [__] creep this guy
sounds like.
>> I think there's zero crossover audience
between me and Adam McIntyre. I saw Adam
McIntyre apparently had a video exposing
a new pedo allegation against
>> it felt like he wanted
>> it
any support financial or otherwise from
Hassan [__]
>> That's so [__] funny, dude. All
right, let's hop back into it.
>> It felt like he wanted to receive credit
from the public from helping me with
>> Yeah, I think she's right. I think he
did. Or he went to help Casey Tron and
Frogan Case or he went to go help Denims
and Frogan and thought Casey Tron
probably could go [__] herself.
>> This is your guy at one point. I'll give
everyone a chance.
>> She's spelled. She's poor. Hassan didn't
give her any money.
>> My question is, was Casey Tron ever in
the inner circle? I don't I never viewed
her as like one of the main orbiters. I
viewed her as somebody who had literally
nothing else to offer, so she tried to
cling on to Hassan. I never saw them as
friends, but I'm not really sure if
that's accurate.
>> Hurtful, especially after he hinted he
might help me become
>> about rape and you're hyping up a who
has a segment on a show called Ultimate
Rape Review.
>> She's broke. She's held hostage. She's
felted. Wo, buddy. Say the line, funny
man. This is so [__] funny. She's a
product of her environment.
>> It felt like he wanted to receive credit
from the public for helping me without
providing any.
>> This is actually how they are. They do
just hear the line after I pay my
attorneys agreed to pay the remaining
fun. No wonder they like [screaming]
>> a power but I read on Snark that THAT'S
NOT HOW THAT WORKS. THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
IT CAN'T HAPPEN LIKE THAT. THE MONEY
CAN'T GO THERE. NO. I READ THAT THAT
CAN'T HAPPEN. They told me it wasn't
going to happen. They told me I WAS
WRONG. THEY TOLD ME THAT'S NOT how the
law works. Oh my god. No. Like how can
you mock other people's terrible legal
analysis built on bias when this is your
stream?
>> OH NO. I really want it's baffling.
[laughter]
>> Dude, thank thank you to Snark for
raising all this money that goes
directly into the client's pocket.
>> The first or second comment at the
beginning wrecked case drawn.
>> Is that what happened? That's diabolical
if true. Dude, she she opened a YouTube
video. It stole somebody's
>> lessons I've learned throughout this
process.
>> I don't think she's learned she's
learned nothing from this. That's why
this is I literally don't think she her
as like one of the main orbiters. I
viewed her as somebody who had literally
nothing else to offer. I also want to
make clear that I did not receive any
support, financial or otherwise, from
Hassan.
>> NO, DUDE. NO, BRO.
OH, maybe this person did. Maybe in
Tonos
>> by stating I take responsibility for
infringing.
>> Or is this the version that was played
on her stream?
>> I think you're wrong.
>> Begin by stating I take responsibility
for infringing the content nuke. The
lawsuit was not frivolous.
>> The alarm was in there. So, she just
[__] this up on her own stream, I
guess, when she showed it. Okay, let's
see.
by stating I take responsibility for
infringing the content nuke. I want to
begin by stating I take responsibility
for infringing the content nuke. The
last was
>> Dude, this is like an ISIS beheading
video. [laughter]
>> Why is he joking after thought of how
much money the other man has? There's
like a very funny like little human
centipede that happened where XQC
basically uh buck broke Ethan totally in
that [__] debate doing the worm.
Totally ruined this guy's mental. Told
him he's got his whole house on his
wrist. Ethan suddenly starts getting
into really expensive watches and really
expensive possessions. He's just
something he was never into before. All
of a sudden wants to showcase wealth and
show how char rich is. And then
curiously when Nick starts getting more
posit
starts obsessing over watches as well.
All of a sudden they oh yeah watches are
how you show wealth. Watch how you show
your cool. Just interesting there. just
interesting there. This guy absolutely
through and through and you know he's
like one of those many guys who I fear I
fear especially cuz I I know Nick uh was
guilty of doing the the type of Destiny
coverage where you spend your time
chasing around after Destiny's ex sexual
partners and uh berating them for their
indiscretions. I know that was something
Nick enjoyed doing for a while.
Um I think he's probably one of these
guys that that just likes the idea of
[__] women with another dude's dick,
you know? I think that's basically
that's what he gets out of the internet
a lot of the time is is like various
forms of [__] women with another
dude's dick whether it's [__] him
legally actually [__] him whatever it
is that's basically where Nick's head's
at
like a [__] this is literally like
Dan Eanata is in the room staring her
down right now
>> not frivolous
>> holy [__] this is amazing this is so
[__] funny
>> by stating I take responsibility for
infringing the content
>> dude can you be a bit more Listen Casey
has anybody ever told you this before
listen cuts you got to smile more You
know, just give them a little bit more
of a smile. I think that they that would
go a long way with the men watching.
>> I want to begin by stating I take
responsibility for infringing the
content nuke. The lawsuit was not
frivolous when I said the lawsuit was
frivolous and based on misogyny.
>> Oh, we got we got timestamped.
>> So [__] funny.
>> And by stating I take responsibility for
infringing the content.
>> Oh, wait. Sorry. I just missed it. I was
looking I was reading a message saying I
just got the time stamp and I missed him
say it, didn't I?
>> A bit more. Listen, Casey. Has anybody
>> [__] ever told you this before? Listen,
cuts, you got to smile more. You know,
just give them a little bit more of a
smile. I think that they that would go a
long way with the men watching.
>> I want to begin by stating I take
responsibility for infringing the
content nuke. The lawsuit was not from
[laughter]
what a [__] weirdo.
Holy [__] Oh my god. Okay, I think
that's about it. I think that's like the
Casey TR apology segment. Tell me guys
there's anything missing. Anything else
I need to say from all this stuff?